[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الخرطوم على وقع
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع الشرقي وجنوبي العاصمه
الى ان يامي واجواء ترحيبا شعبي بالان
باريس اعتزامها سحب السفير والقوات
الفرنسيه من النيجر
الى غوريس الحدوديه جنوب شرق ارمينيا
ومشاهد لافته لنزوح قرابه سبعه الاف من
ارمل كاراباخ الى ارمينيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
قوه دفاع البحرين تعلن مقتل ضابط وفرد
وسقوط جرحى من عناصرها عند الحدود
الجنوبيه للسعوديه وتقول ان الهجوم تم
بمسيره حوثيه وتصفه بالارهابي الغادر
غداه اعلان باريس اعتزامها سحب قواتها من
النيجر واشنطن تنفي اي توجه لخطوه مماثله
وبرلين تقول انها لن تتعجل بشان وضع
قواتها
في تطورات الحرب على اوكرانيا روسيا تعلن
اعتراض صواريخ فوق القرم واسقاط مسيارات
اوكرانيه في اجواء بلغوراد وكيف تعلن وصول
دفعه اولى من دبابات ابرز امريكيه الصنع
سجال روسي امريكي على وقع ازمه كهرباء
رساله دعم من بايدن الى باشنيان الخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول ان الاحداث تؤكد انه لا
يمكن الاعتماد على شراكه روسيا وموسكو
تعتبر ارمينيا رهينه لما سمتها العاب
الغربي الجيوسياسيه
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على
المنصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا التداعيات
المحتمله لاعلان فرنسا اعتزامها سحب
قواتها وسفيرها من النيجر والاستطلاع
ارائكم بهذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي في رايكم كيف سينعكس سحب
فرنسا قواتها على مستوى وحجم نفوذها
بافريقيا جاءت نتائج كالتالي
71% قالوا ان هناك تاثيرا كبيرا على ضوء
انسحاب سابق من مالي وبوركينا فاسو بينما
راى 29% ان الانسحاب له تاثير محدود في ظل
وجود فرنسا في مناطق اخرى بافريقيا هذا
سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا نتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع جنوب وشرق الخرطو
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوه دفاع البحرين مقتل ضابط وفرد
واصابه اخرين في هجوم حوثي على مواقعهم
عند الحدود الجنوبيه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وقالت وكاله انباء البحرين ان
العمل الارهابي الغادر تم بقيام الحوثيين
بارسال طائرات مسيره على مواقع القوه
البحرينيه واضافت ان الهجوم على القوه
البحرينيه جاء رغم توقف للعمليات العسكريه
بين اطراف الحرب في اليمن من جهاته عزا
الامين العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
العاهل البحرينيه او عزه للعهد البحريني
بوفاه الضابط والجندي
من جهتها العتى قوات التحالف اليمن اليمن
هذا
سقوط القتلى والهجوم ودانته معتبره انه
عمل عدائي غادر وقالت ان الاعمال العدائيه
الحوثيه الشهر الماضي شملت استهدافها محطه
كهرباء ومركز شرطه بالمنطقه الحدوديه
لكن لن نذهب الى الرياض الان ينضم الينا
من هناك عبد العزيز بن رازن المستشار
بمركز الاعلام والدراسات العربيه الروسيه
مرحبا بك سيد بن رازن كيف قراتم ما حدث
اليوم
فقدنا اذا الاتصال مع الضيف من السعوديه
من الرياض عبد العزيز بن رازن المستشار
بمركز الاعلام والدراسات العربيه قد نعود
اليه في سياقه حصاد هذه الليله
ونتابع حيث قالت الامم المتحده ان مبعوثها
الى اليمن
هانسيغرام
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض مع كبار
المسؤولين والدبلوماسيين اليمنيين اضافه
الى سفراء الدول الخمس دائمه العضويه في
مجلس الامن واضافت الامم المتحده بان
جراند بيرج التقى السفيره السعوديه لدى
اليمن محمد ال جابر لبحث التقدم المحرز في
الجهود الراميه الى التوصل الى اتفاق بين
الاطراف اليمنيه بشان اجراءات تحسين
الظروف المعيشيه اليمنيين اضافه الى سبل
التوصل الى وقف مستداما لاطلاق النار في
جميع انحاء البلاد واستئناف عمليه سياسيه
جامعه برعايه الامم المتحده واشرت
المنظمه الدوليه الى ان المبعوثه الاممي
جدد تقديره للدعم الذي تقدمه السعوديه
وسلطنه عمان في هذا الصدد
عوده لخبرنا الاول حيث اعلن القوات الدفاع
البحري مقتل ضابط وفرد واصابه اخرين في
هجوم الحوثيه على مواقعهم الحدوديه
الجنوبيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه حول
هذا الموضوع معنى من الرياض مجددا السيد
عبد العزيز بن رازن المستشار بمركز
الاعلام والدراسات العربيه الروسيه سيد
عبد العزيز مرحبا بك معنا كيف قراتم ما جر
اليوم
احييك واحيي مشاهدي قناه الجزيره في كل
مكان بكل تاكيد هذا الخبر المؤسف جدا جدا
وخصوصا في ظل يعني الملف
اليمني والتقارب اليمني
ونظره العالم في التفاؤل الكبير ان يكون
هناك سلام تفاجا العالم باسئله توقع
الشخصي لهذا الحدث ولكن
في قراءه
متى ما يعني تم تبني هذا الخبر من قبل
الحوثي سوف ينسف عمليه السلام التي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ساعتها فيها
وجاده فيها وحقيقه يعني كان يعني هذا
الحدث المؤلم مفاجئ ولا يستغرب حقيقه يعني
بدر الرجوع التاريخ الحوثيين يعني لا
يستغرق عليهم ولكن كانوا متوقع انها فرصه
ذهبيه طالما ان الملف في الرياض وهناك
يعني عده لجان بحضور يعني ممثلين كبار ومن
ض منهم يعني الاعضاء الداعيه في المملكه
العربيه حقيقه مثل هذا الخبر
في قراءتي عن عدم
الرغبه للسلام لدى الحوثيين وهذه تعتبر
يعني
نقطه سلبيه في في واعاقه للملف التي يعني
توقعنا ان يكون يعني ان يرى انه قريبا رغم
الجهود التي يبذلها السفير السعودي في
اليمن مثل هذا الخبر سيكون
يكون انعكاس السلبي جدا على الحوثيه
مدى لا تحرينيه برايك
بكل تاكيد الاستهداف يعني في مثل هذا
الموقع ينمع
العمل مخطط يعني
لا يؤكد يعني النيه صادقه او العمل ولكن
كما تفضلت قبل قليل
كل هذا يعتمد على تبني الحوثي لهذا لهذا
القرار ربما يكون حادث عرضي ربما ولكن
حينما يعني يصدر بيان من الحوثي هنا تتضح
الصوره وتؤكد ان الحوثي ليس لديها رغبات
في السلام وهذا لكل حادث الحديث كما ذكرت
السيد عبد العزيز اذا كان هناك حراك سياسي
مؤخرا لحل الازمه اليمنيه في ظل ايضا
مفاوضات
جرت مؤخرا بهذا الخصوص ما مصير هذا المسار
برايك بعد مثل هذه العمليه
بكل تاكيد
ستكون يعني نقطه تحول
عكسيه تماما في حال ثبات هذا تعمد مثل هذا
الخطر وهذا الحدث الملم الذي يعني كانت
نتيجته يعني شهداء وقتله كما يعني سمعت في
المصادر الرسميه البحرينيه ولذلك يعني
سوف ينسف عمليه السلام برمتها رغم الجهود
المبذوله من المملكه العربيه ومن يعني
الشركاء في ملف اليمن الذي يحاول الجميع
ان ينتشر لليمن من الوعظ الوضع الماساوي
في اليمن الى بر الامان
وبالرجوع لتاريخ لهذه الجماعه في تقدير
الشخصي لا اعتقد انها تريد السلام والايام
سوف تؤكد يعني ذلك او تنفيذ ولكن يعني
كقراءه تحليليه لما يعني
مرير لهذه الجماعه التي الحقت الدمار
الكبير والمعاسي بالشعب اليمني
سيد عبد العزيز بان
مثل هديه متوقعه طالما بان
مسار التفاوض يعني او الوصول الى اتفاق
شامل عن طريق التفاوض لم يتم الوصول اليه
الى فيه الى نقطه يعني محوريه او نقطه
انعطافه قويه
بكل تاكيد القوات المتواجده في في قوه
التحالف يعني تعمل على مدار الساعه وتاخذ
في حسبانها جميع اي اي ظروف طاريه وهذا لا
يحمل يعني لان
لا ينغر الجميع بعمليه السلام وان الملف
لا يزال في يعني
يبشر بالخير وهناك ضوء اخضر وهناك يعني
توقعات ايجابيه لهذا البلد ولكن القوات
المتواجده وتعمل من خلال خططها
الاستراتيجيه
والقائمين عليها على مدارسه طبعا مثل هذا
الحدث متوقع يعني يحدث ولكن يعني يتناقض
فيما يقدمه الحوثي وما يعلنه وما يحضر به
في جعبته للرياض شكرا لك من الرياض عبد
العزيز بن رازن المستشار بالمركز الاعلام
والدراسات العربيه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
لملفني حيث انتهت لعبه تعض الاصابع بين
باريس وسلطات العسكريه في ميامي بعد اعلان
مفاجئ من الرئيس الفرنسي سحب قواته
ودبلوماسيين من النيجر لكن في ظل مخاوف من
تنام النفوذ الروسي تحتفظ الدول الغربيه
الاخرى بمسافه بينها وبين الموقف الفرنسي
اذا اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لم تدخل تغييرات على وجودها العسكري في
النيجر وجدد اوستن خلال مؤتمرا صحفيا
مشتركا مع نظيره الكيني في نيروبي موقف
بلاده الداعي الى حل دبلوماسي للازمه في
النيجر
لم نحدث اي تغيير جوهري في وجودنا العسكري
بالنيجر وكما ذكرت مرارا نريد رؤيه حل
دبلوماسي للازمه في هذا البلد والاهم ايضا
ان تتم المحافظه على الحكومه النيجيريه
المنتخبه ديمقراطيه وفي الوقت الذي نتيح
فيه الفرصه للحلول الدبلوماسيه فاننا
نواصل ايضا تقييم كل الخطوات المستقبليه
من اجل تحقيق الاهداف الديمقراطيه
والامنيه
قال وزير الدفاع الالماني بوريس بستوريوس
سئلنا بلاده ليست بحاجه الى اتخاذ خطوات
عاجله بهذا الشان وانها تراقب الوضع وتضع
الامن نصب اعينها حسب تعبيره ولا فتى
بستوريوس في الوقت نفسه الى انها قاعده
النقل الجويه الموجوده في العاصمه اليامي
مهمه لانسحاب جنوده من دوله مال المجاوره
واخيرا اذا تقرر فرنسا الا جدول من مواجهه
تزداد تعقيدا وماساويه مع النيجر التي
تتصاعد فيها مشاعر العداء لها مع مرور كل
يوم فقد اعلن رئيس الفرنسي
من النيجر والتعهد بسحب قواته كذلك منها
بنهايه هذا العام ويبدو المشهد في كليته
كانه استرجاع لسنوات من حقبه حركات التحرر
الافريقي ضد القوى الاستعماريه ان اكتسب
في ظاهره بالجدل حول الديمقراطيه وحكم
العسكر بالنظر الى انقلابات الغرب
الافريقي تقرير فوزي بشرى
لو كنت ممن يعتقدون بنقصان الاستغلال في
المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه في افريقيا
فانما حققته حركه الاحتجاج الشعبي الرافضه
للوجود الفرنسي في النير لن تبدو لك غير
فصل في استكمال معنى الاستقلال بما يتجاوز
كونه علما ونشيدا فالعلاقه التي رتبتها
فرنسا مع مستعمراتها الافريقيه السابقه
وانتهت الى حاله من الادباع الاقتصادي
والثقافي والسياسي بدرجات متفاوته بين هذه
الدول شهدت اكثر امتحاناتها قسوه
بالانقلابات في مالي وبوركينا فاسو
واكثرها مواجهه بعد الانقلاب الذي وقع في
النيجر قبل شهرين
فبعد اسبوع من الانقلاب يقرر قاده البلاد
تعليق جميع الاتفاقات العسكريه المبرمه مع
فرنسا ثم يتبعون ذلك بقرار طرد السفير
الفرنسي في النيجر وامحاله 48 ساعه
لمغادره البلاد
تقرر فرنسا تحدي قاده الانقلاب بالابقاء
على سفيرها واعتبار ان السلطه الجديده لا
شرعيه لها تخورها طرده
ما تلا ذلك كان مشهدا مثيرا للرثاء ففرنسا
اتهمت بمحاوله فرض محبتها وصداقتها بالقوه
والترهيب على شعب يعلن معظمه كراهيه
وجودها في البلاد
فالمظاهرات لا تنفض الا لتشتمع مره اخرى
امام القاعده الفرنسيه وامام السفاره في
تاييد لقرارات قاده الانقلاب المطالبه
بتصفيه الوجود الفرنسي يتصاعد الرفض
ويتماسك صفه ويتجاسر قاده الانقلاب فلا
يردخون لضغط من فرنسا ولا من المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس التي
هددت مرارا بالتدخل العسكري في النيجر
فذهبت بخطاب الحرب ابعد مما استطاعت ان
تلحق به بندقيه واحده هل فرنسا في ورطه
ربما ورطه الذات الامبراطوريه الجريحه
فالتدخل العسكري مخاطره غير مضمونه
النتائج وقد تثير على فرنسا من الدول
والشعوب من لم يثر من قبل
انتهت فرنسا في النيجر الى قوات حبيسه
وسفير حبيس وقرار حبيس يتقلب اصحابه بين
الخيارات السيئه ثم بدا للرئيس الفرنسي
اللا شيء دائم وربما كان الخروج اليوم
ايسر منه غدا
ثم بدا للرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون ان
لا شيء دائم وربما كان الخروج اليوم ايسر
منه غدا
بالتالي سيعود مع العديد من الدبلوماسيين
الى فرنسا في الساعات القادمه وسننهي
تعاوننا العسكري مع سلطات الامر الواقع في
النيجر لانها لم تعد ترغب في مكافحه
الارهاب وهذا تسبيب لا تنعقد له صله
بالديمقراطيه فتاريخ فرنسا لكثير من
الافارقه في مستعمراتها السابقه موصلته
كانت دائما المصلحه وليس الديمقراطيه
وكانت فرنسا ومعها المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غربيه افريقيا
قد تبنت موقفا متشددا من الانقلاب في
النيجر وطالبتاع باعاده الرئيس المعزول
محمد بازوم الى السلطه واتخذ الاكواس
موقفا مهددا قاده الانقلاب بالتدخل
العسكري ثم انحل العزم ووقع الشك لدى بعض
دول المجموعه من جدوى هذا التدخل ويبدو ان
فرنسا قد انتهت الى من انتهى اليه
المشككون في جدواه اما الولايات المتحده
فلم تنخرط في خطاب عدائي ضد قاده الانقلاب
في النيجر واحتفظت بخطاب دبلوماسي يدعو
بنبره لا حده فيها الى عوده الشرعيه ذلك
كان موقفها في البدء وهو اليوم كذلك
لم نحدث اي تغيير جوهري في وجودنا العسكري
بالنيجر وكما ذكرت مرارا نريد رؤيه حل
دبلوماسي للازمه في هذا البلد
تخرج فرنسا من بعض مستعمراتها السابقه
وتتحسس امريكا موضع اقدامها في قاره تتطلع
الى ثرواتها كل من الصين وروسيا مما
يجعلها مسرحا لمنافسه جديده بين القوى
العظمى الصاعده
ولامريكا تاريخ في وراثه مناطق نفوذ
الامبراطوريتين البريطاني والفرنسي بعد ان
امضى فيهما التاريخ حكمه رافعا وواضعا
معنى من بروكسيل السفير جيمس موران
المستشار السابق في دائره العمل الخارجي
للاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا من النيابه ارحب
بضيفه دكتور علي تاسع الاكاديمي
والدبلوماسيه السابق مرحبا بكم الدكتور
علي فين يامي بعد ان حصلت النيامي على ما
تريده بخروج
فرنسي عسكري ودبلوماسي ايضا من النيجر
ماذا بعد
تحيه طيبه لك واهلا بضيفك الكريم وبمشاهدي
قناه الجزيره
كل ما تريده السلطات العسكريه في النيجر
والشعب النيجري هو ان تخرج فرنسا من
النيجر وتترك هم وشعرهم
والشعب لم يكن يعادي الشعب الفرنسي وكذلك
السلطات لم تكن تعدي الشعب الفرنسي بل ما
كانت ترفضه
السلطه العسكريه هي الاملاءات السابقه هي
التعامل الابوي الذي كان يصدر من فرنسا
تجاهها مستعمراتها السابقه وكذلك الشعب
النيجري الذي معظمه من الشباب يرفض رفضا
قاطعا تلك المعامله التي كانت تعامل فرنسا
بها اباؤهم ابائهم واجدادهم فهم الان
مسقفون وتعلموا في نفس المدارس التي تعلم
فيها الفرنسيون ف لا يمكن لهم ان يقبلوا
تلك المعامله ثم ان ثم ان وسائل الاعلام
وسائل الاتصال اتصالات هذه استطاعت ان
تزيل الغشاوه عن ابصاري الشباب فهم يعرفون
كل ما يحدث في اوروبا وفي العالم باسره
لذلك رفضت الحكومه ورفض الشعب ان تبقى
فرنسا اما ما يحدث بعد انسحاب فرنسا
فالنيجر دوله ذات سياده ولحق في ان تتعامل
مع اي دوله في العالم
فالنيجر لم تقل او اقول السلطات العسكريه
لم تقم لم تقل يوما بانها ستتوجه الى
روسيا او ستستخدم فهي تريد من فرنسا عفوا
ان تخرج ثم انها تستطيع ان تواجه صعوباتها
او تحدياتها بنفسها وما حدث قبل اسبوع
اسبوعين من ائتلاف عسكري وثقافي واقتصادي
بين دول بوركينا فاسو وماليونجر
تعبير صادق اما سيحدث في المستقبل فهذه
الدول تريد ان تجابها كل التحديات التي
امامها سواء كانت اسكان امنيه عسكريه او
اتجاديه او حتى اجتماعيه وثقافيه فهي
متحالفه مع بعضها البعض وتطلب من الدول
الاخرى ان تنضم اليها وانا اعتقد قريبا
ستندم دول اخرى مثل الجزائر وموريتانيا
لانه كان هناك تحالف بهذا الشكل قبل هذا
قبل مجيء فرنسا فجاءت فرنسا وبقيت لعشر
سنوات او ازيد ولم تفعل شيئا نفس المشاكل
التي جاءت من اجلها تزايدت ونفس
موران وهو ضيفي ايضا لشركه بالحديث مثل
هذا النوع من الرسائل الرفض النيجر وشعب
النيجر لسياسه الاملاءات وهذا الارث
الاستعمار الفرنسي الاستعلاء حسب ما يرونه
الذي يقوض القياده النيجيريه مثل هذا
النوع من الرسائل كيف تصل الى الدول
الاوروبيه
اعتقد انه من الاهميه بمكان ان نتذكر
النقطتين بالنسبه الى الماضي اولا ان
الرئيس بزوم في النيجر انتخب منذ اشهر
نتيجه لانتخابات ديمقراطيه يجب ان نتذكر
ذلك النقطه الثانيه هي ان التواجد العسكري
في النيجر ليس فقط فرنسيا بل امريكيا هو
هناك وهناك تواجد لقوات اجنبيه وكان بطلب
من الاداره السابقه في النيجر لذلك نحن
نتحدث عن وضع معقد في النيجر انا افهم ذلك
خير معرفه وهناك تاريخ معقد بين النيجر
والقوه الاستعماريه السابقه ولكن الامر لا
يتوقف عند هذا الحد القلق الاساسي في
اوروبا ليس مرتبطه بهذه النقطه القلق
الرئيس هو ان انعدام الاستقرار يرتفع
منسوبه في المنطقه بما في ذلك النيجر
والمخاوف هي ان هذا الانعدام للاستقرار
سوف يصعب القتال ضد التطرف والارهاب
بالاضافه الى مفاقمه مساله الهجره لذلك
نود ان نرى استقرارا ولكن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه كما قالت بحاجه الى ان
ترى حلا دبلوماسيا الجزائر حاولت ان تقوم
بشيء وايضا في النيجر هناك مخاوف مرتبطه
بانعدام الاستقرار في النيجر وبالتالي يجب
حل هذه المعضله باسرع فرصه ممكنه طبعا
هناك مرحله انتقاليه السؤال هو حول المده
الزمنيه
العسكريون هم لديهم المبادره الان يجب
الاتفاق على مرحله انتقاليه
عندما تتحدث النيجر بسلطاتها الحاليه عن
السياده يعني ينظر الى وجود القوات الاخرى
هي في النيجر ايضا يعني هناك قوات امريكيه
هناك قوات المانيه قوات اخرى بالاضافه الى
ايضا التحدي الذي تحدث عنه سيد جيمس موران
والذي المتمثل يعني الهجمات المتكرره
وارتفاع منسوب عدم الاستقرار مثلا كان
هناك اكثر من عشر هجمات نتجت عنها يعني
اكثر من 100 قتيل منذ الانقلاب في النيجر
تحديدا
مع ذكره ضيفكم من عدم الاستقرار في النيجر
انا اعتقد انه رقم علمه بالنيجر وانا اعيش
في النيجر اذا انا اعلم ما يحدث في النيجر
اكثر منه
عدم الاستقرار الذي يتحدث عنه غير موجود
لا في شوارع مدن النيجر ولا في قرى مدن
النيجر الاستقرار التام موجود الان في
النيجر
في فرنسا
بقيت في النيجر منذ تقريبا
ما يربو على عشر سنوات لكن التهديدات لم
تنقص بل ازدادت هناك عدد من القرى هداك
عدد من المدن هاجرها سكانها رقم وجود
الفرنسي رقم وجود المسيرات الفرنسيه الرقم
وجود الرادارات الفرنسيه اذا اذا لم تكن
هذه الرادارات وهذه المسيرات وهذه القوات
الفرنسيه اذا لم يكن لها اي جدوى في
البقاء في النجف فما الفائده في وجودها
لذلك النيجر مستعد ليواجه هذه التحديات
الامنيه
ماذا يسمى بالتضامني مع الدول الدول
[موسيقى]
الاوروبيه في مقاربتها للعلاقه مع الدول
الافريقيه بعدما جرى
العلاقات مع البلدان الافريقيه تختلف بشكل
كبير من منطقه الى اخرى في افريقيا وان
بلد الى اخر في منطقه الساحل هناك وبكل
وضوح مشكله كبرى لا تتوقفوا عند حدود
فرنسا السودان ايضا يعاني من انعدام
الاستقرار في الوقت الراهن وهي مرحله صعبه
للغايه في العمليات التنمويه طبعا هناك
عمل يجب ان يتم على الجبهه التنمويه في
هذه البلدان ويجب ايجاد الحلول للتعاون
بشكل افضل مع بعضنا البعض ما من ادنى شك
بذلك ولكن هذا النمط استحواذ العسكريين
على السلطه لا يؤدي الى الاستقرار هناك
امثله متعدده في العالم يمكننا ان نعود
اليها حيث ان العسكر لا يؤدي الى
الاستقرار على العسكري لا تؤدي الى
استقرار عاجلا ام اجلا يجب الى الحكم
المدني والى الحل الدبلوماسي الوضع مقلق
الان
المستشار والسابق في دائره العمل
الخادم الاوروبي وايضا اشكر ضيفيه من
النيابه الدكتور علي تاسع الاكاديمي
ودبلوماسيه السابق شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
لحرب روسيا في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مسيارتين اوكرانيتين
في اجواء مقاطعه كورسك فيما اعلن حاكم
مقاطعه
سبع مسيارات في اجواء منطقه غرافو رينسكي
بالمقاطعه اما في القرن فقد اعلن الحاكم
الروسي لمدينه سيفا ستوبل ان قوات الدفاع
الجوي احبطت هجوما صاروخيا قرب مطاري
بيلبك في سفر
وتشهد القرن تصعيدا لافتا فقد اعلن الجيش
الروسي صباح اليوم انظمه الدفاع الجوي
دمرت طائرات مسيره اطلقتها اوكرانيا فوق
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من البحر الاسود
وفوق شبه جزيره القرم في حين قالت القوات
الخاصه الاوكرانيه ان اربعه وثلاثين شخصا
قتلوا في هجوم شنته على مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي في شبه جزيره القرم يوم
الجمعه الماضي بينهم قائد الاسطول فيكتور
سكولوف تتزامن هذه التطورات مع تاكيد
الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي ان بلاده تسلمت
اول دفعه من دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه
ستعود يوما بهذه الثقه يحدثك الاوكرانيون
عن القرم لا تخرج شبه الجزيره التي ضمتها
موسكو عام 2014 عن دائره هجمات كييف
ضمن بنك الاهداف القريبه قياده اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
تقول القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه ان ضربه
الجمعه الماضيه الصاروخيه هناك افضت الى
مقتل 34 شخصا بينهم قائد الاسطول الروسي
فيكتور
واشارت
اخرين اصيبوا في الهجوم هو واحد من هجمات
يقرا فيها خبراء عسكريون صعوبات تواجهها
انظمه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه في صد الضربات
المنتظمه على شبه جزيره القرم مع ذلك تعلن
موسكو بين الفينه والاخرى عن افشال هجمات
بالمسيرات فوق القرم وعلى قطع بحريه روسيه
في البحر الاسود
واتبعت ذلك اخيرا ببيان عن اسقاط طائرات
مسيره عده اطلقتها اوكرانيا لمهاجمه منطقه
تايكورس
الروسيتين لكن لمن الغلبه حقا في الميدان
الثابت انا الاشتباكات لا تنقطع على محاور
القتال المختلفه ولا تنقطع كذلك الهجمات
التي تدار من بعيد في الجنوب الاوكراني
يهاجم الروس جوا بلده في منطقه خرسون كما
يهاجمون بانتظام منطقه اوديسا فتلحق
مسيراتهم وصواريخهم فرط الصوتيه بالغ
الضرر بالبنيه التحتيه لموانئ تصدير
الحبوب الى الشرق يهاجم الاوكرانيون
مستودعات عسكريه في مدينه كراسنودون
بمنطقه لوغانس في اقليم دامباس كما
يتحدثون عن تحقيق المزيد من الاختراقات
على محور بخموت في دنيا
وكذا جنوبا في مقاطعه في محاولتها التقدم
نحو مدينتي ميلوتوبل ديانسك
ومع ان موسكو تنفي تقدم الجيش الاوكراني
على اي من محاور القتال تجاهد كييف لتثبيت
الانطباع بمضي هجومها المضاد بثبات نحو
انجاز اهدافه مما يمكن ان يعين على ذلك
وفاء الحلفاء الغربيين بتعهدات الدعم
والتسليح
نال الرئيس الاوكراني ما وعد به في ثانيه
زيارته الى واشنطن منذ بدء الحرب في بلده
لم يعد زيلينسكي بحزمه جديده من المساعدات
العسكريه فحسب وانما ايضا بتفعيل الوعد
الامريكي بتسليم الجيش الاوكراني احدى
وثلاثين دبابه من طراز ابرامز ام واحد
مزوده بذخائر مضاده للدروع
اكدت بالفعل تسلمها اول دفعه من تلك
الدبابات وجرى اعدادها لتعزيز الالويه
الاوكرانيه
تنقل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه عن
مسؤولين في واشنطن قولهم ان دبابات ابرامز
امريكيه صنع وصلت الى اوكرانيا في الوقت
المناسب
معنى من اوديسان نتاليا المتحدثه باسم
قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني
سيده نتاليا مع تاكيد وصول الدفعه الاولى
من دبابات ابرامز ما هو المتوقع ان تحدثه
من فارق عسكري في جبهات القتال
المعدات او اي اسلحه هذا دعم حقيقي ومهم
خاصه عندما يكون الحديث عن اسلحه متطوره
وقويه من الممكن ان تدافع عن ارواح جنودنا
وان تساعد في تدمير العدو
دبابات ام برامز تنقل صحيفه نيويورك في
واشنطن بانها وصلت الى اوكرانيا في الوقت
المناسب ما الذي يعنيه هذا التوقيت
بالنسبه لكم
اي توقيت حيث العدو على اراضينا هو وقت
مناسب لاستخدام هذه المعدات ولتحرير
اراضينا هذا ما يحدث هناك اعمال فعاله
ونحن نحتاج للدعم ونحتاج لهذه المساعدات
وبكل السعاده نحصل عليها كانت قد استلمت
اوكرانيا ايضا دبابات تشالنجر البريطانيه
لكن ادائها القتالي لم يكن كما كان متوقعا
منها
يعني هل تعولونا بالتالي على ما سيقدم
الان من قبل الامريكيين
لنا اي دعم عسكري كما قلت سابقا هو دعم
مهم
ومؤثر هل قد يتناسب هذا مع بعض التوقعات
او مع مع يقرا به الواقع البعض هذا كله
يعتمد على القياده العسكريه على ارض
المعركه وكل الدبابات التي حصلنا عليها
تستخدم في المهام
المتناسبه وهذا يساعدنا في تدمير العدو
ومواقعه لذلك المساله هنا اننا نتعامل مع
جيش اكبر منا بكثير بالعدد والعده ولكن
الاراده لدينا اكبر بكثير اذا ما انتقلنا
الى الهجمات المتواصله والمتكرره على شبه
جزيره القرم
ما نوع الاستراتيجيه العسكريه من وراء
الاستهداف الاوكراني لشبه جزيره القرم
بهذه الصوره ومدينه سيفل تحديدا
قمنا بالتنبيه مسبقا اننا سوف نقوم بتدمير
كل معدات وذخيره
العدو ومراكيل لتجمع
وكل هذا قد يستخدم ضدنا لذلك نحن
نقوم بهجمات على اهداف شرعيه لنحرر القرم
وكل اراضينا وبالتالي كيف ستضيف مثل هذه
الهجمات بالاضافه الى استلام المزيد من
الاسلحه على المعركه في الجنوب التي تجري
خاصه في
زبروجيا وخيرسون وانت متحدثه بقياده
العمليات الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني
هذا سليم نحن نتقدم ولكن نتقدم ببطء لان
لدى العدو خطوط دفاع قويه وتتكون من مراحل
ويجب علينا ان نقوم بتخطي كل هذه المسافات
ولكن بالحفاظ على جنودنا لذلك المعدات هذا
شيء مهم للدفاع عن المشاه ونحتاج ايضا
اسلحه بعيده المدى تسمح لنا ان ندمر العدو
على مسافات طويله حتى نتقدم ونحن نستخدم
كل ما يتم استلامه من الشركاء
شكرا لك
السيده نتاليا المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات
الجنوب في الجيش الاوكراني حدثنا من
اوديسا وارحب بضيفي من موسكو فيكتور
العسكري والعقيد في الجيش
الروسي العقيده الاحتياط في الجيش الروسيا
مرحبا بكم معنا ما نوع
وما ترتيب الاولويات الروسيه الان في ظل
خضم هذه المعركه مع استمراريه عمليه الدعم
والامداد من قبل الغرب للقوات الاوكرانيه
ووصول دبابات ابرمز
الى ساحات القتال
اولا الدعم الغربي هو قليل ورمزي عشر
دبابات او عشرين دبابه او ثلاثين هذا
لا يلعب اي دور اساسي في الجبهات التي
تمتد الى حوالي 1200 كيلو متر الشيء
الثاني الدبابات الامريكيه هناك مثل روسي
يقول ما فائده الميت في الحديقه ما يحتاج
الميت للحديقه يعني لو توضح لنا هذه
الفكره يعني في النهايه هناك
اختراق حدث في خطوط الدفاع وحتى وان كان
محدودا والتقدم بطيئا ولكن هناك اختراق في
خطه الدفاع الاول
هناك اي تقدم في الواقع ليس لديهم شيء لم
يقتربوا حتى الى الخطوط الاولى من الدفاع
ولا في اي محور من المحاور خلال ثلاث اشهر
من هذه الحرب خسروا 71 الف جندي
والكثير من المعدات المدرعه الاف على سبيل
المثال خلال عشر سنوات من الحرب في
افغانستان الجيش السوفيتي خسر خمسه عشر
الف وهم في ثلاث اشهر خسروا واحد وسبعين
الف شخص ونحن خلال
ثلاثين سنه خسرنا في افغانستان عشره اذا
اوكرانيا يرسلون جنودهم الى مفرمه لحم ولا
ينجحون في الوصول الى اي شيء
دباباتهم مثل شالنجر واليا بارد وايضا
ابرهامش كل هذا سوف يشتعل كما اشتعلوا من
ضرباتنا
النظر عن الدعايات التي يقومون بها عن هذه
المعدات اذا ما انتقلنا الى استراتيجيه
اخرى ايضا
للجيش الاوكراني بالاضافه لما تحدثت عنه
يعني ولكن يعني هناك استهداف متكرر متواصل
شبه جزيره القرم تريد كيف تثبيته ضمن
معادله معينه كيف تقراه موسكو
المحاولات بالضربات بالمسيرات او
الصواريخ الالمانيه او الامريكيه او
الانجليزيه
هذه اعمال ارهابيه قبل كل شيء ونحن
نقوم بالسيطره على هذه الصواريخ واسقاطها
نعم ليس هناك درع كامل قد لا يخترق بعض
الصواريخ فعلا تصل وتضرب
او غيرها ولكن
هذه الطريقه لن تصل الى اي شيء ولن يصل
الى الى اننا سوف نحرر نيكا لايف واوديسا
من حيث تنطلق هذه الضربات وسوف تقطع الطرق
بين كيف والبحر الاسود ثم لن يستطيع
القيام بهذه الضربات
الخبير العسكري والعقيده الاحتياط في
الجيش الروسي شكرا على المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
وصلت الى العاصمه الارمينيه يا ريفان
مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه
سما ساباور التي قالت انها جاءت الى
يريفان بتكلفه من الرئيس جو بايدن لتاكيد
التزام واشنطن بسياده ارمينيا على اراضيها
تزامنا تزامن هذا هذه الزياره تزامنت مع
وصول وزير الداخليه الروسي فلاديمير
الى العاصمه الارمنيه ما في اذربيجان
فاستقبل الرئيس الهام عليف نظيره تركيه
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي قال نباكو نفذت
عمليه ناجحه ضد الارهاب في كندا داعيا
ارمينيا لاغتنام فرصه الاستقرار والسلام
وفق تعبيره
صوب ارمينيا يتقاتل سباق سياسي متناقض
الاطراف وفد امريكي رفيع يصل العاصمه
ريفان يضم ثمن سباور مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه ويوريكيم
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وصفت باور
توقيت الزياره بالمهم للمنطقه تاكيدا لدعم
العلاقات الثنائيه وتحدث مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الارميني ان مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه اكدت على دعم من سيجلون من
اقليم كرباخ على وقع زياره بعث الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن رساله الى رئيس الوزراء
الارميني مؤكدا تعزيز التعاون بين واشنطن
وريفان ودعم سياده ارمينيا على اراضيها
العلاقات مع واشنطن تنظر اليها بريبه
موسكو التي ارسلت في نفس اليوم الى ريفان
وزيره داخليتها فلاديمير كولوك سيف ليشارك
في اجتماع موسع للجنه الامنيه الثنائيه
المشتركه مع نظيره الارميني باغي سريعا
تتهم السلطات الارمينيه موسكو صراحه
بالخذلان في ملف كارباخ بل سبق لرئيس
الوزراء نيكولا ان صرح باخفاق روسيا في
مهمه حفظ السلام في الاقليم الكريم من
جانبه رفض ذلك مؤكدا على تحالف الجانبين
وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان القياده في
ريفان ترتكب خطا كبيرا عبر محاوله تدمير
العلاقات مع روسيا وجعل البلاد رهينه لما
وصفتها بالاعيب الغرب الجيوسياسيه قد تلمح
اشاره الكرملين الاخيره الى التقارب
الارميني الامريكي لكن واشنطن ليست وحدها
في سياق التعاطي الخارجي مع ازمه كاراباخ
المزمنه الدعم التركي لاذربيجان بالمقابل
غير خافل ولم يتوقف عند حدود حرب 2020 بل
كان مشهده الاحدث وصولا الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان الى اذربيجان مؤكدا على ان
العلاقات بين البلدين في اعلى مستوياتها
وداعيا ارمينيا للسلام
ننتظر من ارمينيا ان تصافح اليد التي
امتدت اليها وان تلتزم بالصلح وكما قلنا
دائما لا خاسر ابدا من السلام لقاء
الرئيسين التركي والادربيجاني تم في منطقه
بالحكم الذاتي وهي شريط واقع بين ارمينيا
وايران وتركيا وتريد انقره وباكو ربطها مع
الجزء المتبقي من اذربيجان من خلال انشاء
ممر بري يمر عبر جنوب ارمينيا بموازات
السباق الاقليمي والدولي على النفوذ تنعقد
في كاراباخ جوله ثانيه من المباحثات بين
قيادات الارمن والسلطات الاذربيجانيه
لتخفيف بقايا الاحتقان الاخير كانت على
الطاوله ملفات الدمج وتسليم السلاح وحل
المجموعات المسلحه الارمينيه في الاقليم
معنى من لندن جميله ماما دوفا الباحثه في
شؤون القوقاز ودول الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا
سيتم مرحبا بك معنا هل ستستطيع واشنطن ان
تثبت وجودها في ارمينيا ارمينيا هي يعني
من الدول التي تعتبر ضمن الفضاء الجيو
السياسي الحيوي بالنسبه لروسيا
هلا بك كان سبيك ناو
تفضلي
كريم
مساء الخير سلمى شكرا على هذه الاستضافه
نعم هناك تطورات مهمه في المنطقه
ولا اذكر المره الاخيره التي زار بها وفد
امريكي الى المنطقه ايضا هناك توقيع
لاتفاقيه غاز كبيره في اذربيجان اذا هذا
مؤشر كبير طبعا هناك محاولات في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الوصول الى حل
ومحاوله احلال الاستقرار في المنطقه
المسورون الامريكيون لم يدلوا باي تصريح
مرتبط
بالاباده او التطهير العرقي او كل هذه
الخطابات التي استمعنا اليها في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من قبل الجانب الارميني
هذا مؤشر ايجابي اذا هناك محاولات واضحه
لارساء الاستقرار والسلام في المنطقه
والوصول الى حل لهذا النزاع للمضي قدما من
خلال المفاوضات
وحقيقه بارمينيا ام انها مهتمه اكثر
بوجودها في هذا الفضاء ضمن عمليه التنافس
الروسي الامريكي واذا ما وضعنا طبعا
بالاذهان ما يجري في اوكرانيا
اعتقد ان الجميع بما في ذلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يحاول ان ينتهز هذه
الفرصه خصوصا في اطار الذي اشرت اليه الا
وهو الحرب في اوكرانيا ولكنها ايضا فرصه
بالنسبه الى ارمينيا واذربيجان للتوصلي
الى نوع من الاتفاقات السلميه الاسره
الدوليه تدعم هكذا اتفاق برايي طبعا
بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
هناك مصالح
واذربيجان كانت من بين الشركاء الرئيسيين
للولايات المتحده في المنطقه
الامريكيون لديهم تواجد في جورجيا ولديهم
تواجد في المنطقه وبالتالي هناك حضور
امريكي هناك وجود كبير دبلوماسي وسفاره
كبيره في ارمينيا ولذلك انا شخصيا لم
اتفاجا بهذا الموقف كيف تبدو لك صياغه
التحالف ات الجديده بعد جوله القتال هذه
وما تلاها من ترتيبات هي تسير اكثر باتجاه
اذربيجان
اعتقدوا انه
يتعين علينا ان ننتظر لنرى النتيجه
النتيجه ليست واضحه المعالم اذربيجان
لديها علاقات سياسيه مقربه من روسيا ولو
انها حاولت ان تضع مسافه بينها وبين
الكريم ان تخطو بخطط متوازنه بالنسبه الى
هذه العلاقه السياسيه لا اعتقد ان تطورات
التي تحصل في المنطقه يمكن ان تحصل من دون
موافقه روسيا برايي وطبعا هناك موقف روسي
لا يدعم اي من الطرفين ولكن بالنسبه الى
الارمانيين طبعا هناك حق لهم بان يرفع
الصوت ويقولوا ان روسيا لم
تبلغ بلاء حسنا بالنسبه الى ارساء التفاهم
اذا هناك وجود ميدانيا لروسيا ولكن غياب
على المستوى الدبلوماسيه ان هناك حاجه
للانتظار لكي نعرف ما الذي سوف يتم تناقش
بشانه مع
ممثليباخ من
الاصول الارمنيه مع السلطات
اذربيجانيه لكي نرى المسار المستقبليه اذا
اعتقد ان المقاربه بنى ولكن يتعين علينا
ان ننتظر لنرى النتيجه شكرا لكن
الباحثه في شؤون القوقاز ودول الاتحاد
السوفيتي سابقا شكرا على المشاركه
ارتفع عدد النازحين الارمن من كراباخ عبر
ممر لاتشي صوب ارمينيا الى نحو 7000 شخص
خلال الساعات الماضيه ومن المتوقع ان
تتواصل حركه النزوح الجماعي خلال الايام
المقبله والصمخاوي الفامنيه
لم يعد هذا الطريق خاليا كسابق عهده يغص
بحركه اولئك الذين نزحوا من بيوتهم في
كاباخ الى ارمينيا
تصحبهم في تلك الرحله قوات حفظ السلام
الروسيه عبر ممر لاتشين يرحلون بما
استطاعوا حمله من متاع وذكريات
اختار معظمهم الصمته على التحدث عما جرى
غير ان حكايه النزوح حاضره في وجوه الجميع
على الحدود تستقبلهم نقطه للرعايه الاوليه
تحدد احتياجاتهم
بعضهم لهم اقارب في ارمينيا لاسيما ممن
نزحوا خلال حرب عام 2020
واخرون سينتقلون الى مراكز الايواء
الحكوميه قرب الحدود بعد اكثر من 30 عاما
من الحرب توضح الهجره الكبيره لارمن
الاقليم انعدام الثقه بين طرفي الصراع
الاف وصلوا خلال ساعات من فتح الحدود
ويستمر تدفق المزيد منهم نحو مستقبل
مجهول المعالم
غوريس اقرب المدن الى ممر العدشين والوجهه
التاليه بسكان الاقليم في الساحه الرئيسيه
للمدينه ركنوا سياراتهم حيث يوفروا لهم
الماوى وبعض الاساسيات
لم نستطيع ان ناخذ كل اغراضنا تركنا
الكثير وراءنا لكن الاسوا اننا تركنا
وراءنا الوطن مسرح كوريس اصبح مركزا
لايواء مئات اللاجئين لكنه ليس الوحيد في
المدينه
وتعمل منظمات دوليه ومحليه على مساعده
القادمين في مسائل عده
فضلا عن التنسيق لتنفيذ بنود اخرى من
اتفاق وقف الاعمال العدائيه
كما نستعد لسد حاجات الاعداد الكبيره من
القادمين ونعمل مع السلطات الارمينيه
وشركائنا على تامين حاجات اخرى كمساعده
اولئك الذين تفرقوا عن ذويهم على مدى عقود
اسفرت الحرب في المنطقه عن تهجير اكثر من
مليون شخص من الطرفين بحسب الامم المتحده
فصول كثيره من الصراع وصلت الى نهايته حاب
اتفاقيات الحرب الاخيره
لكن ملف النزوح ليس واحدا منها
محمود الزيبق الجزيره
غوريس
الى السودان حيث تجددت اليوم المعارك في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش وسط الخرطوم في
الاثناء قالت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان
طائرات مسيره تابعه للجيش السوداني قصفت
اهدافا لدعم السريع قرب المدينه الرياضيه
حيث تتمركز قوه للدعم واضافت المصادر ان
الجيش السوداني قصف مواقع لقوات الدعم
شرقيه الحاج يوسف في الخرطوم وافاد مراسل
الجزيره باندلاع اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم حول المنطقه الفاصله بين القوتين
شرقي ام درمان
جاني بها قالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
اسقطت طائره حربيه من طراز ميغ تابعه
للجيش السوداني في الخرطوم واضافت في
منشورا على منصه اكس ان من وصفته بنظام
المؤتمر الوطني بقياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
ينتهج سياسه الارض المحروقه بالقصف
المتعمد للاحياء السكنيه والاسواق في مدن
العاصمه الثلاث وبعض الولايات في دارفور
وكوردفان
[موسيقى]
وفي ولايه جنوب دارفور قالت مصادر
السودانيه للجزيره ان الاشتباكات المباشره
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
تجددت في مدينه نيالا عاصمه الولايه بعد
ان توقفت لعده ايام واشارت المصادر الى ان
الاشتباكات بدات بهجومه من قوات الدعم على
قياده الجيش من الناحيه الشماليه ونقوات
الجيش تصدت للهجوم دون وقوع خسائر بين
المدنيين
الدكتور اسامه عيدروس الاكاديميه
السودانيه المختص بشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه دكتور اسامه مرحبا بك معنا اكثر
من خمسه اشهر والمعارك لا زالت مستعره
خاصه في منطقه الخرطوم مدن الخرطوم الثلاث
لماذا هي في الحقيقه ليست مستعره بهذا
المعنى لانه في فرق كبير جدا في مستوى
المعارك من بدايه الحرب وحتى الرابع من
يوليو الماضي منذ الرابع من يوليو الماضي
انحسرت المعارك بشكل كبير وتحولت قوات
الدعم السريع يعني الى التمترس داخل
الاحياء في هيئه في في في الدفاع يعني
تهيات للدفاع استراتيجيه للدفاع وانتظرت
الجيش للتحرك اليها استراتيجيه الجيش
مختلفه ما زال يدافع عن الاراضي الحيويه
بالنسبه له وهي المعسكرات الثابته للجيش
التي يمكن ان ينطلق للتطويق الدعم السريع
طالت مده انتظار الدعم السريع للجيش فبدات
في مناوشات للجيش كان هنالك هجوم عنيف جدا
على المدرعات في التاسع عشر من اغسطس
استمر لفتره وانتهى انحسر كانت عمليه
استنزاف كبير للدعم السريع ثم تحولت بعده
الى اماكن اخرى من القياده العامه التي
اسامه هذه الخريطه التي تتحدث عنها يعني
كل يوم نسمعها في الاخبار
ويعني هناك حاله يعني عدم حسم حتى الان ما
مردوها يعني هذه المراوحه في المكان تقدم
وصد وهجوم هي في الواقع انتشار الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم وسط الاحياء المدنيه
جعل من الصعب جدا اخراجه منها
بسلاسه دون التسبب في يعني وفيات واسعه
وخسائر في ارواح المدنيين لكن الملاحظه
يلاحظ انه الجيش له خطه ثابته في التقدم
نحو نقاط حاكمه المعارك الان من الجيش
تقدم الجيش
يعني الحديث حتى في الخبر جاء الحديث عن
هجوم في شرق ام درمان في المناطق الفاصله
بين الجيش والدعم السريع الجيش يتقدم
هنالك بخطى حديثه ومتقدمه يكسب كيلومترات
متقدمه كل يوم هذه هي التضييق الاخيره على
الدعم السريع اذا نجح الجيش في تلاحم
قواته من جنوب ام درمان مع شمال ام درمان
تصبح ام درمان يعني منطقه حاكمه لا يستطيع
الدعم السريع جلب اي امداد لقواته من
الغرب ليدخلها الى الخرطوم هذه خطه الجيش
الان وهي تسير على الارض
يحسم المشهد ضمن هذه القتال المستمر منذ
خمسه اشهر كما ذكرت في البدايه وخاصه بان
القتال ايضا يجري في منطقه دارفور وفي
كردفان وان الوضع هناك سيء ولا ننسى بان
البرهان تحدث من على منبر الامم المتحده
وقال بانه الجيش لا يستطيع ان يغطي كل
المناطق قتاليا هو القتال نفس الان انحسر
بشكل كبير كما قلت لك في البدايه يعني حتى
عندما نقول قتال في دارفور ليس كما كانت
في البدايه انما هي هجوم او هجومين بعربات
اعداد قليله جدا
تدور فيها معارك وتنحسر وتنتهي المعركه في
اقل من ساعه يعني هكذا حتى الهجمات الان
داخل الخرطوم من الدعم السريع هي كانه
يقول انا موجود او يريد ان يعطل الجيش او
يريد ان يكسب نقاط سياسيه في مناطق فقدت
قيمتها العسكريه القيمه العسكريه الحقيقيه
في الخرطوم اذا استطاع الدعم السريع اسقاط
وادي سيدنا وفيها السلاح الجو
او المدرعات او المهندسين وفيها سلاح
المدفعيه وهذه اصبحت بعيده عن متناوله
بعيده جدا عن انه يسقطها او يتقدم نحوها
تتحدث عنه دكتور اسامه الوضع الانساني
القطاع الصحي وضع الاحتياجات هو سيء جدا
في السودان هذا الوضع على من يضغط من
الاطراف هذا الوضع يضغط على السودانيين
جميعا كل السودانيين الان يعانون من اطاله
امد الحرب هذه الحرب ما كان ينبغي لها ان
تطول لولا تدخل اطراف خارجيه تقوم بتقديم
الدعم لقوات الدعم السريع لتواصل القتال
في استنزاف كانها مجموعات تزحف نحو الموت
يعني الموت في اسوار القياده العامه الموت
في اسوار المدرعات موت بالجمله موت مجاني
موت رخيص لا معنى له الا اذا كان فعلا
هنالك اطراف خارجيه هي التي تحرك هذا
القتال وحتى قيادات الدعم السريع فقدت
الصوت السيطره والقدره على ايقاف هذا
القتال المستمر في اطراف الخرطوم هذه
الحرب الان تمضي الى نهايتها خسر
السودانيين فيها كثيرا خصوصا في الجانب
البشري الذي لن يعوض شكرا جزيلا لك في
الاستديو الدكتور اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي
السوداني المختص بشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
شكرا
مستمرون معكم في حصاد الليله وفي العناوين
قوه دفاع البحرين تعلن مقتل ضابط وضابط صف
وسقوط جرحا من عناصرها عند الحدود
الجنوبيه للسعوديه وتقول ان الهجوم تم
بمسيره حوثيه وتصفه بالارهابي الغادر
والتحالف يدين ويقول ان الهجوم ياتي في
سياق اعمال عدائيه سابقه طالت محطه كهرباء
ومركز شرطه
غداه اعلان باريس اعتزامها سحب قواتها من
النيجر واشنطن تم في اي توجه لخطوه مماثله
وبرلين تقول انها لن تتعجل بشان وضع
قواتها
في تطورات الحرب على اوكرانيا روسيا تعلن
اعتراض صواريخ فوق القرم واسقاط مسيارات
اوكرانيه في اجواء بلكوره وكيف تعلن وصول
دفعه اولى من دبابات ابرز امريكيه الصنع
سجال روسي امريكي على وقع ازمه كهرباء
رساله دعم من بايدن الى باشنيان الخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول ان الاحداث تؤكد انه لا
يمكن الاعتماد على شراكه روسيا وموسكو
تعتبر ارمينيا رهينه لما سمتها العاب
الغربي الجيوسياسيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قوه دفاع البحر مقتل ضابط وضابط صف
واصابه اخرين في هجوم الحوثيين على
مواقعهم عند الحدود الجنوبيه للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقالت وكاله انباء
البحرين ان العمل الارهابي الغادر تم
بارسال الحوثيين طائرات مسيره لمواقع
القوه البحرينيه واضافت ان الهجوم على
القوه البحرينيه جاء رغم توقف في العمليات
العسكريه بين اطراف الحرب في اليمن من
جانب هذانت قياده القوات المشتركه للتحالف
باليمن في بيان دانه الهجوم واعتبرته عملا
عدائيا غادرا في سياق الاعمال العدائيه
خلال الشهر الماضي اضافه ان الاعمال
العدائيه الحوثيه الشهر الماضي شملت
استهداف محطه كهرباء ومركز الشرطه
بالمنطقه الحدوديه من جهته عزا الامين
العام لمجلس التعاون الخليجي عزه العائله
البحريني بوفاه الضابط وضابط الصف
هذا وقال المستشار المركز الاعلامي
والدراسات العربيه الروسيه في الرياض عبد
العزيز بن رازن ان تداعيات حادثه الهجوم
على موقع القوى البحرينيه عند الحدود
الجنوبيه السعوديه ستتضح في حال تبنت
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين لهجوم بشكل
رسمي واضاف بالرازن في مقابله مع الجزيره
ان صدوره مثل هذا الموقف قد ينسف عمليه
السلام الجاريه في اليمن
في قراءه متى ما يعني تم تبني هذا الخبر
من قبل الحوثي سوف ينسف عمليه السلام التي
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ساعتها فيها
وجاده فيها وحقيقه يعني كان يعني هذا
الحدث المؤلم مفاجئ ولا يستغرب حقيقه يعني
بدر الرجوع التاريخ الحوثيين يعني لا
يستغرق عليهم ولكن كانوا متوقع انها فرصه
ذهبيه طالما ان الملف في الرياض وهناك
يعني عده لجان بحضور يعني ممثلين كبار ومن
ضمنهم يعني الاعضاء الدائمه في المملكه
العربيه حقيقه مثل هذا الخبر في قراءتي عن
عدم
الرغبه للسلام لدى الحوثيين
معناه من بيروت يوسف دياب الكاتب الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي يوسف مرحبا بك معنا كيف
تابعت هذا الخبر اسمع منك تعليقك في
البدايه
مساء الخير طبعا يعني هو خبر مفاجئ وصادم
لان هذا التطور هو يعتبر تطور خطير
وربما يعني
ينذر
بانقلاب الوضع راسا على عقب منذ ان ابرم
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني في التين لشكل
اليوم ان يعني علينا كمراقبين ان ننتظر
للدرجه الاولى
الموقف الرسمي للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والموقف الرسمي بالبحرين رغم البيان
السريع الذي صدر عن التحالف وعن يعني
المرجعيات البحرينيه ايضا علينا ان ننتظر
ما اذا كان جماعه الحوثي ستتبنى هذه
العمليه ولكن بالمنطق اليوم يعني لا ليس
هناك اي جهه خارجيه ممكن ان تنفذ مثل هذه
العمليه
الجماعات الحوثيه التي كنا نراقب في
الساعات الماضيه اجراء عمليات مناوره
واستعراضات عسكريه لها في صنعاء وكان
الامر مخالف لكل الاجواء السياسيه وكل
التهدئه التي كنا نشهدها في الاشهر
الماضيه ايضا هي مخالفه لكل المبادرات
التي تبذلها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اليوم للتقريب بين
الاطراف اليمنيه المتصارعه واعني الحكومه
الشرعيه
وجماعه الحوت شك ان هذا الحادث سيترتب
عليه نتائج ينتظر ان تتبلور او تتظاهر في
الساعات المقبله لكن بكل تاكيد هو عمل
خطير وغير محسوب او ربما غير
مسبوق من يعني منذ ان نوقع الاتفاق
الايراني
السعودي وعلينا ان نفهم
سيد يوسف هل من دلاله معينه ان يحصل
الهجوم على القوى البحرينيه تحديدا
نعم يمكنني يمكن اختيار الهدف بشكل يعني
دقيق ربما يريد من يقف وراء هذه العمليه
والترجيحات تذهب باتجاه الحوثي للقول
بانها لا غير معنيه بالتصعيد مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او استهداف المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بل هي استهدفت موقعا
عسكريا بحريا لكن واضح اليوم ان بيان قوات
التحالف هو بيان حاسم لجهه ان استهداف
موقع بحريني عسكري هو استهداف لكل قوات
التحالف ولكل دول الخليج التي
معنيه بالدرجه الاولى بالسلام في اليمن
والمعنيه بالتهدئه بشكل اساسي والتي كانت
حريصه كل الفتره الماضيه على تثبيت
الاتفاق الايراني السعودي وترجمته على
الارض بدءا من
اليمنيه لا شك كل يوم اننا يعني كنا نشهد
في الايام الماضيه بعض الاشارات او بعض
التقارير من قبل الاعلام السعودي الذي
يركز على تجاوزات ترتكبها قوات الحوثيه
سواء في الدخل اليمني في صنعاء لجهه
استهداف مساعدات
يفترض ان تدخل الى المناطق المحاصره او
عمليات تستهدف بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر
القوات الحكوميه اليمنيه لكن اليوم هذه
العمليه جاءت عمليه مباشره وهي الاولى من
نوعها منذ ان وقعت التهدئه بين الطرفين
لذلك انا اعتقد اليوم ان هذا الحادث
سيترتب عنه نتائج ونتائج اعتقد انها نتائج
خطيره خصوصا اذا نتائج على مسار المفاوضات
الذي كان ينظر اليه بانه مسار ايجابي
بالتاكيد يعني اذا اذا المسار السياسي لن
يرسي هدوءا واستقرارا ولن يؤسس الى سلام
في الداخل اليمني بشكل اساسي وسلام يمني
مع جيران اليمن فهذا يعني ينعي كل
المبادرات السابقه وكل محاولات التهدئه
السابقه هذا يعني ان السعوديه او الامارات
العربيه او
البحرين او كل دول الخليج تحاور في المكان
الخطا ومع الجهه الخاطئه اعتقد اليوم ان
الحوثي ومن خلال هذه العمليه واذا ما
تبناها في الساعات المقبله هو يرسل رسائل
تتعدى الجغرافيا اليمنيه او المنطقه
المتنازله والمناطق الحدوديه مع مع اليمن
بل هي انا اعتقد انها رسائل ايرانيه
اقليميه ودوليه تريد من خلالها ان تقول
بان لديها اوراق قادره ان تلعبها سواء في
اليمن وسواء في سوريا وسواء في لبنان من
خلال التصعيد الذي بدا يتبدى من قبل حزب
الله سواء بالنسبه لدوره في سوريا
والتهديد بان اي عمليه لقطع الامدادات
الايرانيه باتجاه سوريا ولبنان ومن ثم
فلسطين يعني المحاولات الامريكيه لقطع
الحدود العراقيه السوريه او محاولات
استهداف سياسي لحزب الله من خلال
الاستحقاقات الدائمه هذا يعني ان الامور
ستذهب باتجاه منح اخر وهو منحى تصعيدي نحن
نرى اليوم التصعيد سياسي ولكن يمكن اي
فجاه باي مرحله او باي وقت الى تصعيد
عسكري وهذه الرساله هي مؤشر لما قد
يوسف دياب الكاتب الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
ورح
ب بضيفي من لندن احمد المؤيد اكاديمي
والباحثات
السياسي اليمنيه سيد احمد المؤيد
تعليقكم بالبدايه على ما جرى اليوم
نعم تحيه لكم وللمشاهدين الكرام في
الحقيقه ان لم يتبنى احد من يعني من طرف
صنعاء هذا الهجوم ولكن اذا وصفنا واقع
الحال فالحرب لم تقف اساسا وما تسمى
بالهدنه هي غير موجوده ربما هناك يعني
تهدئه ولكن هذه التهدئه على ارض الواقع هي
قصف سعودي يومي يعني على على الحدود
السعودي على الحدود اليمنيه وعلى القرى
اليمنيه في مناطق رازح ومنبه والملاحيض
يوميا تقريبا يعني مثلا منذ بدايه عام
2023 هناك
تبعين ما بين قتيل والجريح نتيجه قصف
المدفعيه السعوديه للاراضي اليمنيه القصه
يعني المهم في الموضوع او الجديد في
الموضوع ان لا احد يتحدث عندما يسقط فتله
يمنيين او ضحايا يمنيين لا جريح ولا قتيل
لو يقصف لو يسقط عشره ولا عشره الف لا احد
يتحدث لا يتحدثون الا عندما يسقط ضابط
بحريني طيب لماذا تتواجد قوات بحرينيه على
الحدود اليمنيه السعوديه
اذا كانت اذا كانت السعوديه جاده في عمليه
السلام وغيرها ماذا تفعل قوات بحرينيه
يعني على الحدود لماذا تقصف المدفعيه
السعوديه كل يوم القرى اليمنيه انا اتوقع
انه المساله هي اذا حصلت فهي ردت فعل من
قبل القوات اليمنيه التي ضاقت درعا بالقصف
السعودي اليومي على الاراضي والقرى
اليمنيه والمدارس والتي كل يوم نحن نتابع
يعني كل يوم نرى انه يعني كانت الانباء
لم تتبنى لماذا لم يتبنى الحوثي حتى الان
او لم يصدر عنه اي تعليق حول ما جرى اليوم
لا اعتقد ان هناك حاجه لتبني لاننا اعرف
يعني نحن نعرف السابق ان هناك يعني قصد
متبادل ما بين يعني قوات صنعاء وما بين
السعوديين اليوم لانه يعني سقط ضابط
بحريني فيجب ان تنتفض الدنيا وان تقوم
صنعاء وتتبنى يعني
لا اعتقد ان اساسا للتبني
ين ارخص من دماء البحرين مثلا وتستاهل
مثلا انه بحرين سقط يجب ان تعلن صنعات
النفير العام وتعلن وتتبنى العماليه لا
تحتاج ان تتبنى يتوقف القصف السعودي
سيتوقف القصف اليمني المساله بسيطه
التحالف يقول بان الهجوم ياتي في سياق
الاعمال العدائيه التي يقوم بها الحوثي
خلال الشهر الماضي ما معنى ان تستمر مثل
هذه الاعمال في الوقت الذي يجري الحديث
فيه عن تفاوض
حقيقه النفس التساؤل كنا نطرحه انا عن
نفسي طرحته قبل اكثر من شهرين عندما تحرك
السفير السعودي الى صنعاء في رمضان الماضي
وقلت ماذا يفعل السفير السعودي في صنعاء
وقواته اليوم اسقطت كذا كذا يمنيين
وبالامس اسقطت كذا كذا يمنيين في قرى
يمنيه ماذا يفعل سفير السعودي في صنعاء
عام اي سلام يتحدث وقواته قصفت بالامس
وقصفت اليوم ومؤقت ستقصف غدا وبعد غد والى
اخره اليوم 370 يعني ضحيه وشهيد من من
بدايه العام لحد الان السؤال هو لماذا
تقصف السعوديه الاراضي اليمنيه وهي تتحدث
عن سلام فضلا عن انها تحاول الترويج انها
وسيط بين اليمنيين كيف وصلت اليمنيين من
الذي كان يقصف اليمن منذ تسع سنوات مثلا
هل هي دوله اخرى انا اول وساطه اراها في
العالم لا يعتبر بها الوسطاء بل ان طرفا
من الاطراف كل يوم يكرر انت لست وسيطا انت
طرف فهذه المساله يعني ما يقال في الاعلام
يجب ان نراه على ارض الواقع اما
ان يقال شيء ويطبق على ارض الواقع شيء اخر
هذا الكلام غير ممكن ولا اعتقد ان
الصناعات تسمح به وخصوصا في يعني منذ هذه
الايام
اعتقد انه سيؤثر نعم سيؤثر على مسار
المحادثات يعني صنعاء يبدو انها وخصوصا
بعد خطاب الرئيس المشاط اليوم هناك يعني
نوع من الحزم في الخطاب ان السعوديه لا
تستطيع ان يعني تعمل على عامل الوقت
وما يقال هو غير ما يرى يعني هذا لا ينسجم
مع روح السلام لا شكلا ولا مضمونا يجب ان
يتجه الجميع نحو السلام بنيه صادقه وان
يرى ما يقال في الاعلام او في الكواليس
على ارض الواقع اما المدفعيه السعوديه كل
يوم تقسم القرى اليمنيه ولا يتحدث احد ولا
يظهر ذلك في الاخبار الا اذا سقط ضابط
بحريني هذا هذه قسمه طيزه حقيقه هذا امر
غير عادل مطلقا شكرا
قالت الامم المتحده انها مبعوثها الى
اليمن هانس جراند اجرى مباحثات في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض مع كبار المسؤولين
والدبلوماسيين اليمنيين اضافه الى سفراء
الدول الخمس دائمه العضويه في مجلس الامن
واضافت الامم المتحده بان جرام
لدى اليمن محمد ال جابر لبحث التقدم
المحرز في الجهود الراميه الى التوصل الى
اتفاق بين الاطراف اليمنيه بشان اجراءات
تحسين ظروف المعيشيه لليمنيين اضافه الى
سبل التوصل الى وقف مستدام لاطلاق النار
في جميع انحاء البلاد واستئناف عمليه
سياسيه جامعه برعايه الامم المتحده واشارت
المنظمه الدوليه الى ان المبعوثه الاممي
جدد تقديره للدعم الذي تقدمه السعودية
وسلطنه عمان في هذا الصدد
اكد وزير الدفاع الامريكيسن نواشنطن لم
تدخل تغييرات على وجودها العسكري في
النيجر وجدد اوستن خلال مؤتمر صحفيا مشترك
مع نظيره الكيني في نيروبي موقف بلاده
الداعي الى حل دبلوماسيا للازمه في النيجر
لو كنت ممن يعتقدون بنقصان الاستغلال في
المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه في افريقيا
فانما حققته حركه الاحتجاج الشعبي الرافضه
للوجود الفرنسي في النير لن تبدو لك غير
فصل في استكمال معنى الاستقلال بما يتجاوز
كونه علما ونشيدا فالعلاقه التي رتبتها
فرنسا مع مستعمراتها الافريقيه السابقه
وانتهت الى حاله من الادباع الاقتصادي
والثقافي والسياسي بدرجات متفاوته بين هذه
الدول شهدت اكثر امتحاناتها قسوه
بالانقلابات في مالي وبوركينا فاسو
واكثرها مواجهه بعد الانقلاب الذي وقع في
النيجر قبل شهرين
فبعد اسبوع من الانقلاب يقرر قاده البلاد
تعليق جميع الاتفاقات العسكريه المبرمه مع
فرنسا ثم يتبعون ذلك بقرار طرد السفير
الفرنسي في النيجر وامحاله 48 ساعه
لمغادره البلاد
تقرر فرنسا تحدي قاده الانقلاب بالابقاء
على سفيرها واعتبار ان السلطه الجديده لا
شرعيه لها تخورها طرده
ما تلا ذلك كان مشهدا مثيرا للرثاء ففرنسا
اتهمت بمحاوله فرض محبتها وصداقتها بالقوه
والترهيب على شعب يعلن معظمه كراهيه
وجودها في البلاد
فالمظاهرات لا تنفض الا لتشتمع مره اخرى
امام القاعده الفرنسيه وامام السفاره في
تاييد لقرارات قاده الانقلاب المطالبه
بتصفيه الوجود الفرنسي يتصاعد الرفض
ويتماسك صفه ويتجاسر قاده الانقلاب فلا
يردخون لضغط من فرنسا ولا من المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا اكواس التي
هددت مرارا بالتدخل العسكري في النيجر
فذهبت بخطاب الحرب ابعد مما استطاعت ان
تلحق به بندقيه واحده هل فرنسا في ورطه
ربما ورطه الذات الامبراطوريه الجريحه
فالتدخل العسكري مخاطره غير مضمونه
النتائج وقد تثير على فرنسا من الدول
والشعوب من لم يثروا من قبل
انتهت فرنسا في النيجر الى قوات حبيسه
وسفير حبيس وقرار حبيس يتقلب اصحابه بين
الخيارات السيئه ثم بدا للرئيس الفرنسي
اللا شيء دائم وربما كان الخروج اليوم
ايسر منه غدا
قررت فرنسا سح
وبالتالي سيعود مع العديد من الدبلوماسيين
الى فرنسا في الساعات القادمه وسننهي
تعاوننا العسكري مع سلطات الامر الواقع في
النيجر لانها لم تعد ترغب في مكافحه
الارهاب وهذا تسبيب لا تنعقد له صله
بالديمقراطيه فتاريخ فرنسا لكثير من
الافارقه في مستعمراتها السابقه موصلته
كانت دائما المصلحه وليس الديمقراطيه
وكانت فرنسا ومعها المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غربيه افريقيا
قد تبنت موقفا متشددا من الانقلاب في
النيجر
وطالبتابعاده الرئيس المعزول محمد بازوم
الى السلطه واتخذ الاكواس موقفا مهددا
قاده الانقلاب بالتدخل العسكري ثم انحل
العزم ووقع الشك لدى بعض دول المجموعه من
جدوى هذا التدخل ويبدو ان فرنسا قد انتهت
الى من انتهى اليه المشككون في جدواه اما
الولايات المتحده فلم تنخرط في خطاب عدائي
ضد قاده الانقلاب في النيجر واحتفظت بخطاب
دبلوماسي يدعو بنبره لا حده فيها الى عوده
الشرعيه ذلك كان موقفها في البدء وهو
اليوم كذلك
لم نحدث اي تغيير جوهري في وجودنا العسكري
بالنيجر وكما ذكرت مرارا نريد رؤيه حل
دبلوماسي للازمه في هذا البلد
تخرج فرنسا من بعض مستعمراتها السابقه
وتتحسس امريكا موضع اقدامها في قاره تتطلع
الى ثرواتها كل من الصين وروسيا مما
يجعلها مسرحا لمنافسه جديده بين القوى
العظمى الصاعده
ولامريكا تاريخ في وراثه مناطق نفوذ
الامبراطوريتين البريطاني والفرنسي بعد ان
امضى فيهما التاريخ حكمه رافعا وواضعا
معناها المختار ولد الشين الخبير في الشان
الافريقي المختار هل
العطب في العلاقه بين فرنسا
ومستعمراتها السابقا النيجر مالي وبوركينا
فاسو هو عطب غير قادر للاصلاح
اولا شكرا على الاستضافه على قناتكم
المتميزه من خلالكم حي مشاهديكم مشاهديكم
الكرام
في الحقيقه هذا العطب مؤقت
ونواصل الرئيس الفرنسي
بسياسته
ثرثرته
وعدم احترامه لهذه الشعوب وهذه الدول
سيؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه مستقبليه وسيكون
المستفيد اولا منها
انا اختلف مع البعض ستكون جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه
وقلب ذلك روسيا الاتحاديه المهم ان ان
فرنسا بسبب سياسه ماكرون كما قال صاحبكم
في التقرير اصبحت حبيسه هذه الشعوب كانت
تعتبر فرنسا مثلا يحتذى به اي قيم البرنسب
الثوره الفرنسيه ولكن على اساس ان ان
الفرنسيين مغايرين للشعوب الاخرى الاحترام
كان هو الاساس واذا غير الفرنسيون لاسلوب
فسيعاملونهم الافارقه مثل كل شعوب الاخرى
هذا هو من ناحيه هنا المجلس العسكري عندما
انقلب على محمد بازوم وهنا للتذكير النيجر
27 مليون نسمه صوتت في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه 15% من سكانها يعني تم انتخاب
محمد بازوم بعشره فقط من 27 مليون نسمه
ذلك الامريكان عندما اخذ ذلك المنحه قالوا
اتركونا مع الديمقراطيه الافريقيه
والديمقراطيه النيجر
براكماتيه
وملاحظه الامور المهمه وهي محاربه للارهاب
ومحاربه التقدم روسيا الاتحاديه عن طريق
هل ترى بان ما جرى لهذه العلاقه التي
انكسرت الان بين فرنسا وهذه الدول هو
نتيجه عسكره العلاقه مع الدول الافريقيه
في بيئه تسخر
بالازمات الامنيه خاصه والمجتمعيه ام انه
يعني نتيجه سياسه
الاملاءات والاستعلاء
لفرنسا مع ارثها الاستعماري
هنالك شيء من ذلك ولكن المهم ان في فرنسا
مثلا رؤساء فرنسا في الجمهوريه الخامسيه
من دوجول الى فرنسا تراه والى جاك شراك
كان يمثل القوه الهاديه
اما سيد ماكرون عندما بدا 2017 اصطدم
بمنظومته الخارجيه الدفاعيه كانت استقاله
الجنرال قائد القوات الاركان الجيش
الفرنسي وبدا هو باسلوب خاص يعني الثرثره
وعدم احترامي ومحاوله ولا فارقه ليس فارقه
بالتكنولوجيا وبمعرفه وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ما يحدث في اجداس
يعرف به بارز والعكس ولذلك
هذه
الفرنسيين اتوا 2013 من اجل محاربه
الارهاب ولكن تقييم عشر سنوات من من سياسه
الارهاب في نيجر وفي اي منطقه ما زالت
الجماعات المتشدده تسيطر على مثلا حدود
الثلاثه للدول الثلاثه النيجر وبوركينا
فاسو ومالي يعني هنالك تقدم كذلك من
جماعات بوخو حرامي القادمه من نيجيريا
وكذلك الدواعش القادمين من موزمبيق ومن
الكاميرون هذا كله لسببه ان فرنسا
سياستها الامنيه لا يواكبها دبلوماسيه
ايجابيه
والاهتمام بالشعب الشعوب هذه الاقتصاد
الاقتصاد وبنى تحتيه اساسيات تتبع للجميع
مواقبه فرنسا من ناحيه ايجابيه شكرا من
نواه المختار ولد الشين اخي الخبير في
الشان الافريقي شكرا على المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
لا حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مسيرتين اوكرانيتين
في اجواء مقاطعه كورس فيما اعلن حاكم
مقاطعه بيلجو الروسيه اسقاط سبع مسيرات في
اجواء منطقه
جرافيورنسكي بالمقاطعه اما في القرن فقد
اعلن الحاكم الروسي لمدينه سلفا لان قوات
الدفاع الجوي احبطت هجوما صاروخيا قرب
مطار
ستعود يوما بهذه الثقه يحدثك الاوكرانيون
عن القرم لا تخرج شبه الجزيره التي ضمتها
موسكو عام 2014 عند دائره
ضمن بنك الاهداف القريبه قياده اسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبول
الثابت انا الاشتباكات لا تنقطع على محاور
القتال المختلفه ولا تنقطع كذلك الهجمات
التي تدار من بعيد في الجنوب الاوكراني
يهاجم الروس جوا بلده بريسلاف في منطقه
خرسون كما يهاجمون بانتظام منطقه اوديسا
فتلحق مسيراتهم وصواريخهم فرط الصوتيه
بالغ الضرر بالبنيه التحتيه لموانئ تصدير
الحبوب الى الشرق يهاجم الاوكرانيون
مستودعات عسكريه في مدينه كراسنودون
بمنطقه لوغانس في اقليم دامباس كما
يتحدثون عن تحقيق المزيد من الاختراقات
على محور بخموت في دنيتك
وكذا جنوبا في مقاطعه زابروجيا في
محاولتها التقدم نحو مدينتي ميلوتوبل
وبرديانسك
ومع ان موسكو تنفي تقدم الجيش الاوكراني
على اي من محاور القتال تجاهد كييف لتثبيت
الانطباع بمضي هجومها المضاد بثبات نحو
انجاز اهدافه مما يمكن ان يعين على ذلك
وفاء الحلفاء الغربيين بتعهدات الدعم
والتسليح
الرئيس الاوكراني ما وعد به في ثانيه
زيارته الى واشنطن منذ بدء الحرب في بلده
لم يعد زيلينسكي بحزمه جديده من المساعدات
العسكريه فحسب وانما ايضا بتفعيل الوعد
الامريكي بتسليم الجيش الاوكراني 31 دبابه
من طراز ابرامز ام واحد مزوده بذخائر
مضاده للدروع
اكدت بالفعل تسلمها اول دفعه من تلك
الدبابات وجرى اعدادها لتعزيز الالويه
الاوكرانيه
تنقل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه عن
مسؤولين في واشنطن قولهم ان دبابات ابرامز
امريكيه الصنع وصلت الى اوكرانيا في الوقت
المناسب
وصلت الى العاصمه الارمنيه يا ريفان مديره
الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه سماسا
باور التي قالت انها جاءت الى يريفان
بتكلفه من الرئيس جو بايدن لتاكيد التزام
واشنطن بسياده ارمينيا على اراضيها تزامنا
هذا تتزامنت هذه الزياره الامريكيه مع
وصول وزير الداخليه الروسي فلاديمير كولو
الى العاصمه الارمينيه
صوب ارمينيا يتقاتل سباق سياسي متناقض
الاطراف وفد امريكي رفيع يصل العاصمه
ريفان يضم ثمن سباور مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه ويوريكيم
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وصفت باور
توقيت الزياره بالمهم للمنطقه تاكيدا لدعم
العلاقات الثنائيه وتحدث مكتب رئيس
الوزراء الارميني ان مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه اكدت على دعم من سيجلون من
اقليم كرباخ على واقع زياره بعث الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن رساله الى رئيس الوزراء
الارميني مؤكدا تعزيز التعاون بين واشنطن
ودعم سياده ارمينيا على اراضيها العلاقات
مع واشنطن تنظر اليها بريبه موسكو التي
ارسلت في نفس اليوم الى ريفان وزيره
داخليتها فلاديمير كولو كول سيف ليشارك في
اجتماع موسع للجنه الامنيه الثنائيه
المشتركه مع نظيره الارميني باغي
تتهم السلطات الارمينيه موسكو صراحه
بالخذلان في ملف كارباخ بل سبق لرئيس
الوزراء نيكولا ان صرح باخفاق روسيا في
مهمه حفظ السلام في الاقليم الكريم من
جانبه رفض ذلك مؤكدا على تحالف الجانبين
وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان القياده في
ريفان ترتكب خطا كبيرا عبر محاوله تدمير
العلاقات مع روسيا وجعل البلاد رهينه لما
وصفتها بالاعيب الغرب الجيوسياسيه قد تلمح
اشاره الكرملين الاخيره الى التقارب
الارميني الامريكي لكن واشنطن ليست وحدها
في سياق التعاطي الخارجي مع ازمه كاراباخ
المزمنه الدعم التركي لاذربيجان بالمقابل
غير خافل ولم يتوقف عند حدود حرب 2020 بل
كان مشهده الاحدث وصولا الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان الى اذربيجان مؤكدا على ان
العلاقات بين البلدين في اعلى مستوياتها
وداعيا ارمينيا للسلام
ننتظر من ارمينيا ان تصافح اليد التي
امتدت اليها وان تلتزم بالصلح وكما قلنا
دائما لا خاسر ابدا من السلام لقاء
الرئيسين التركي والادربيجاني تم في منطقه
بالحكم الذاتي وهي شريط واقع بين ارمينيا
وايران وتركيا وتريد انقره وباكو ربطها مع
الجزء المتبقي من اذربيجان من خلال انشاء
ممر بري يمر عبر جنوب ارمينيا بموازات
السباق الاقليمي والدولي على النفوذ تنعقد
في كاراباخ جوله ثانيه من المباحثات بين
قيادات الارمن والسلطات الاذربيجانيه
لتخفيف بقايا الاحتقان الاخير كانت على
الطاوله ملفات الدمج وتسليم السلاح وحل
المجموعات المسلحه الارمينيه في الاقليم
معنى من موسكو
الباحثون في العلاقات الدوليه ومعنا ايضا
من واشنطن ويليام السفير الامريكيه السابق
في جورجيا ومساعد الرئيس كلينتون لشؤون
روسيا مرحبا بكم
قالت وبتكليف من الرئيس بايدن بانه يؤكد
التزام واشنطن بسياده ارمينيا على اراضيها
ما تعريف التزام واشنطن لسياده ارمينيا
على اراضيها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ومنذ انهيار
الاتحاد السوفياتي وكان هناك خمسه عشر و15
دوله استحدثت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
دعمت الاستقلال والسياده على اراضي كل تلك
البلدان بما في ذلك ارمينيا
واوكرانيا والدول الاخرى وبالتالي هذه
السياسات تستمر وهذا يعني ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لا تدعم انفصال البلدان
وانضمامها الى بلدان اخرى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ترى ان المهمه الرئيسه
هي مرتبطه بالجانب الانساني نتحدث عن
الالاف من الارمينيين الذين سوف يغادرون
انغورنو كاراباخ ويتجهون باتجاه ارمينيا
وهو امر يشكل ضخطا على القدرات
ولذلك الدول الغربيه والولايات المتحده
تحاول ان تساعد
وسياده ارمينيا على كامل اراضيها بعد ان
خسرت الحرب امام اذربيجان وعمليه النزوح
للارمن من كربه باتجاه ارمينيا ام انها
مهتمه بمناكفه روسيا في مثل هذا الفضاء
الجيو السياسي الحيوي بالنسبه لها
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدعم
الاستقلال والسياده على الاراضي الارمينيه
ولكن ذلك لا يتضمن اقليم ناغورنو كارباح
حيث ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والدول الاخرى ترى ان هذا الاقليم هو جزء
من اراضي ازار بادجان اذا نعم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تدعم السياده الاراضي
الارمنيه على الاراضي الارمنيه
يعني كيف وصلت الامور الى حد مثل هذا
الاتهامات المتبادله بين موسكو ويريفان
يعني اتهامات مباشره بينهما عما جرى في
كهرباء
كما تعرفون نحن نتحدث عن قصه طويله
المشاكل مع ارمينيا بدات منذ سنوات متعدده
عددا كبيرا من النخبه الارمنيه قرر ان لا
يتحمل المسؤوليه بالنسبه الى العلاقات
العسكريه والحرب التي بدات مع اذربيجان
النخبه الارمنيه قررت ان تلقي اللوم على
روسيا اذاء كل المشاكل وطبعا
يشعر بها الطرف الارميني الان خاصه مع مثل
هذه الخساره
يعني الى اي درجه هذا الامر قد يجعل الامر
مدخلا لوجود واشنطن ضمن هذا الفضاء المهم
بالنسبه لموسكو
روسيا ولا ارمينيا
ترى ان ناغورنو هي اقليم مستقل او دوله
مستقله الجميع يعرفوا ان هذا الاقليم هو
جزء من ازار جنوب التالي بالنسبه الى
روسيا ما من مشكله بالنسبه الى انغورنو
كهربا حتى ارمينيا لم تقر بان ناغورنو هو
بلد مستقل وبالتالي ليس الخطا خطا روسيا
هناك نخبه في ارمينيا تودوا ان تلقي اللوم
على روسيا اذا كل شيء اما بالنسبه الى
موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نعم
اعتقد ان ارمينيا تحاول ان تستند الى دعم
غربي بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
التي لديها شتات ارميني كبير فيها ولكن
اعتقد ان ارمينيا سوف يتعين عليها ان
تعتمد في على روسيا في نهايه المطاف لانه
قد تنشف حرب بالنسبه الى الاراضي
الارمينيه مع اذربيجان ومناطق المرتبطه
بالممر الاساسيه الذي يربط الاراضي
الاذربجين الداخليه مع منطقه نهيشيبان
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن مساله معقده حرب
جديده قد تنشر ومن دون مساعده روسيه لا
فرنسا ولا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سوف
تساعد ارمينيا عسكري
ة التي تحاول
واشنطن صياغتها في منطقه القوقاز
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تحاول ان
تستحدث وتنسج علاقات وتحالفات جديده في
هذا الجزء من العالم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تشارك كجزء من حلف شمال الاطلسي
وهذا تواجد دفاعي عسكري امني
وهذا هو التواجد الروسي اما بالنسبه الى
ما قاله الضيف من روسيا هو على حق بالنسبه
الى ارمينيا ما تقوم به ارمينيا تلقي
اللوم على روسيا لان روسيا لم تمنع
اذربيجان من السيطره على اقليمي ناغورنو
كاراباخ ولكن في المقام الاول لم يكن هناك
اعتراف بان هذا الاقليم لديه استقلال
وبالتالي ارمينيا على الارجح سوف تتجه نحو
الغرب بشكل اكبر
وتبتعد عن التحالف مع روسيا
مثل هذا الكلام
هل من الممكن ان تكون ارمينيا ساحه
التنافس جديده في خاصره روسيا
يمكن ان تكون ساحه التنافس
وبالنسبه الى ارمينيا اود ان اقول كما
سبقوا اسلفت انها بحاجه الى روسيا في حال
اصبح هناك مشكله مع اذربيجان الاناني اشك
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او فرنسا
سوف تشارك عسكريا في اي حرب مستقبليه وفي
الوقت نفسه الغرب لا يمكنه ان يعتمد على
ارمينيا بشكل حصري لان اذربيجان دوله مهمه
بالنسبه الى اوروبا من حيث امدادات الغاز
والطاقه
كانت المنقذ
بخصوصي موضوع
الغاز والنفط الروسي والعلاقه الصعبه مع
اوروبا وبالتالي اعتقد ان الدول الغربيه
سوف تحاول ان تؤدي دور الشرطي الجيد ان
تنسج العلاقات مع ارمينيا ولكن من دون ان
تنسى
الباحث المختص في العلاقات الدوليه ومن
واشنطن ويليام الامريكيه السابق في جورجيا
ومساعده رئيس كلينتون لشؤون روسيا شكرا
جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
قبل ثلاثين عاما تم توقيع اتفاقيه اوسلو
بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وكانت لهذا الاتفاقيه تداعيات
كثيره على الوضع الفلسطيني في مجالات عده
نقف في مدينه بيت جالا المحاذيه لبيت لحم
تصنف هذه المنطقه في داخل المدينه الف لكن
على بعد امتار قليله ننتقل الى منطقه جيم
فما هي هذه التصنيفات وهل ما زالت قائمه
فعلا ام انها مجرد حدود وهميه قبل ثلاثين
عاما قسمت اراضي الضفه الغربيه بموجب
اتفاقيه اوسلو الى مناطق الف وباء وجيم
تصنيف كان يفترض ان يسري لخمس سنوات فقط
الى حين التوصل الى اتفاق دائم بين
الجانبين وهو ما لم يحدث حتى يومنا هذا
سنبدا من المنطقه الف وهي عباره عن مراكز
المدن الفلسطينيه وتشكل نحو
18% من مساحه الضفه الغربيه
وبحسب اتفاقيه اوسلو فانها تخضع مدنيا
وامنيا للسلطه الفلسطينيه
لكن على ارض الواقع فان قوات الاحتلال
تقتحم هذه المناطق بشكل يومي منذ سنوات اي
انه لم يعد هناك فرق بينها وبين مناطق با
وهذا ياخذنا الى المناطق المصنفه باء وهي
عباره عن الامتداد الريفي للمدن تدير
شؤونها المدنيه السلطه الفلسطينيه لكنها
امنيا تخضع لسلطات الاحتلال
وعندما نتطرق الى الجانب الامني فهذا لا
يعني انها بحمايه امنيه اسرائيليه وانما
هي مناطق يقتحمها الاحتلال ويعتقل
الفلسطينيين من داخلها ويهدم المنازل فيها
تشكل المناطق المصنفه الف وباء مجتمعه نحو
ثلث مساحه الضفه الغربيه وقد تحولت الى
مناطق مقتظه جدا اذ يعيش بها اكثر من 90%
من مجمل السكان الفلسطينيين في الضفه
الغربيه ولماذا
ننتقل الى مناطق جيم
ابقت اتفاقيه اوسلو اكثر من 60% من اراضي
الضفه الغربيه تحت سيطره اسرائيل مدنيا
وامنيا لذا فقد شهدت هذه المنطقه المصنفه
جيم اكبر عمليات الهدم والتهجير وبدل ان
تشكل متنفسا للفلسطينيين من اجل التوسع
والبناء اصبحت شبه دوله
للمستوطنين فقد استغلت اسرائيل اتفاقيه
اوسلو غطاء للتوسع الاستيطاني الذي تضاعف
منذ اذا اربع مرات بينما تضاءل الوجود
الفلسطيني بفعل ممارسات الاحتلال وسياساته
التهجيريه
واعتداءات المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين
اكبر خطيه صارت بالنسبه لاوزلو كانت عدم
المطالبه بوقف الاستيطان
واستكفوا
بالمصطلح الذي صاغه الامريكان عندما قالوا
بانه ان لا يقوم اي طرف من الاطراف باي
خطوات احاديه الجانب ستؤثر على قضايا الحل
النهائي اعتبر هذا بالنسبه للفلسطينيين
انه هذا يعني وقف الاستيطان
اما القدس فظلت خارج هذه التصنيفات
لمفاوضات الحل النهائي كقضيه اللاجئين
والحدود والمياه لكن بعد ثلاثين عاما لم
يتم التوصل الى حل بل استغلتها اسرائيل
وفرضت الكثير من الحقائق على الارض فاصبحت
قضيه الاستيطان التي اعتبرت حينها قضيه
هامشيه واحده من قضايا الحل النهائي
نجوان سمري الجزيره الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
فقره المتابعه لحصاد الليله نخصصها للتعرف
اكثر على دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه التي
تلقت كييف اليوم اولا دفعه منها وفق ما
اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي دبابه ام 1
ابرامز يبلغ طولها نحو عشره امتار
وارتفاعها حوالي مترين ونصف المتر بينما
يفوق وزنها 73 طنا وسرعتها القصوى 68 كيلو
مترا في الساعه ابرامز المزوده بمحرك
النفاث يعملوا بالكيروسين مثل الطائرات
تتسع لفريق من اربعه افرادهم قائد الدبابه
والسائق والمدفعي والمسؤول الذخيره
والدبابه ايضا مجهزه بثلاثه رشاشات
وبمدفع عيار 120 مليمتر يفوق مداه الفعال
اربعه كيلو مترات وهي قادره على حمل 40
قذيفه واكثر من 11 الف طلقت رشاش وفق
وعودا امريكيه سابقه فان دبابات ابرامز
المخصصه لاوكرانيا ستك المزوده بذخائر
مضاده للدروع تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
ومنذ دخولها الخدمه عام
1980 تطورت دبابه ابرز عبر نسخ مختلفه
ويمكن ان يزيد سعر الواحد منها على عشره
ملايين دولار ميدانيا يقول موقع امريكان
امريكان سيكيوريتي بروجيكت ان دببه ابرامز
والاعتبارات تتعلق بالوقود والوزن
والصيانه قد تكون اكثر فائده في المواقف
الدفاعيه لا في الخطوط الاماميه
وبوصول الدبابات الامريكيه اليها تكون
القوات الاوكرانيه قد حصلت على اهم ثلاثه
انواع من الدبابات الغربيه ذائعه الصيد في
الحروب ففي مارس الماضي ارسلت بريطانيا
الى كيف اربعه عشره دبابه من نوع تشالنجر
اثنين
وفي الشهر نفسه تسلمه اوكرانيا من برلين
ثمانيه عشره د من طراز
اثنين ايضا الالمانيه واليوم وصلت اول
شحنه دبابات ابرز الامريكيه ضمن تعهدً ينص
على تزويد كيف باحدى 30 دبابه منها معنى
لاكثر صوره اوضح عن هذه الدبابه واهميتها
من اكسفورد فرانك ليدويد كبير الخبراء
العسكريين في مؤسسات
جلوب ساك للدراسات مرحبا بك السيد
اذا ما نظرت الى
وجود هذه الدبابات على ساحه المعركه ما هي
الاضافه بالنسبه بالنسبه لك كمتابع
حقيقه هذه الدبابات هي شبيهه من المنظور
الوظيفي والقدرات
الالمانيه التي اشرتم اليها ولك والتي
استخدمتها اوكرانيا في الاشهر السته
الاخيره هي افضل قليلا لديها
محرك
الف
ومتطلب اكثر للجهه اللوجستيه في موضوع
الهندسه حتى من التي هي متقدمه ولكن لا
اعتقد ان هذه الدبابات سوف تصنع فرقا
اساسيا في الميدان حيث ان عددها قليل
للغايه ولا وضعه في المرحله الراهنه على
جبهات القتال ليس مثاليا باستخدام
الدبابات اصلا
لتكون فعاله اكثر في ادائها القتالي في اي
جبهات سيكون
الدبابه لديها وظيفه هجوميه وهي لا تؤدي
بشكل جيد في مجال التكتيكات الاوكرانيه
على سبيل المثال لا تتفاعلوا بشكل جيد مع
الالغام الارضيه الدبابات تحب الحركه وان
تتحرك من منطقه الى اخرى
والروس عززوا الدفاعات في الاجزاء
الجنوبيه من اوكرانيا بشكل يهدف على وجه
الخصوص الى وقف التقدم عبر الدبابات والى
الحق الضرر بالدبابات وهذا ما قام به
الروس بالنسبه الى هذه الدبابات
البريطانيه
الالمانيه لا نتحدث عن فرق كبير بالقدرات
بالنسبه الى المدى ولكنها جيده جدا
بالنسبه الى المجموعه في داخلها هي تحمي
الدب المجموعه في داخلها وهي تختلف بشكل
جذري من هذا المنظور عن الدبابات
السوفياتيه القديمه التي تستخدمها
اوكرانيا باعداد كبيره
كان هناك يعني حديث ناقد عن يعني الاضافه
يعني للدبابات التي تمت تسلمها من طراز
وايضا
بان ادائها القتالي ليس مهما وانها من
طراز قديم جدا يعني وكان هذا النقد شديد
وجه
لهذه النوعيه من الدبابات برايك هل
يعني سيكون الامر مختلف مع دبابات ابرز
الامريكيه
نعم هذه نقطه مثيره للاهتمام بشكل كبير
كان هناك انباء بان الدبابات التي قدمتها
المانيا الى اوكرانيا دبابات لم تكن جاهزه
للقتال الوظيفه القتاليه لم تكن جاهزه
ولذلك تم سحب عدد كبير منها من الخدمه
واستخدام هذه الدبابات للاحتياط انا اعتقد
اتوقع انه بالنظر الى الوقت الذي كان
بحوزه الامريكيين لتجهيز هذه الدبابات
ال31 هي جاهزه دبابات للقتال وسوف تكون
جاهزه للقطار ولكن كما سبق واسلفت عددها
قليل
والظروف الميدانيه ليست مثاليه لاستخدام
هذه الدبابات
شكرا لك اذا فرانك ليدويتش الكبير الخبراء
العسكريين في مؤسسات جلوب ساك للدراسات
حدثتنا من اكسفورد شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نتذكر محنه
تابعنا تفاصيلها في المغرب وليبيا خلال
الاسبوعين الماضيين لكن مع التفاصيل
المؤلمه تابعنا ايضا مشاهد انسانيه لافته
في مواجهه الزلزال شكل التضامن الشعبي
للمغاربه مع المتضررين امر اللافتات حيث
تفاعل المواطنون مع المبادرات الشخصيه
والمدنيه للتكافل ويتذكر الجميع المشاركه
الواسعه التي يعبر عنها المغاربه استجابه
لمناشدات السلطات للتبرع بالدم وفي ليبيا
اثارت الفيضانات المدمره موجه تضامن
تجاوزت الانقسامات السياسيه والقبليه بين
شرق البلاد وغربها تكثر المساعدات الموجهه
الى الناجين خصوصا في وقت طرفيه عشرات
الالاف الى النزوح من المناطق المتضرره
وهم مشردون ومن دون اي موارد وتشهد وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي دعوات كثيره لاواء
نازحين صحيح ان فقد الاحبه لا يعوض ودمار
امر مؤلم لكن مشهد التضامن الانساني قد
تخفف حجم الماساه دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]